أنت في الصفوف الأمامية التي
تراها تحدث ، لذا أخبرنا فقط كيف يبدو الأمر
عندما تكون في المستشفى هذا الأسبوع
مقارنة بالماضي ،
أعني أنني أعتقد في كلمة واحدة أنه أمر
مفجع في المرة الأخيرة
كنت في الخدمة ، اعتنيت بخمسة مرضى
مصابين بفيروس
كوفيد وتعافي أحد هؤلاء المرضى
وتمكنت من الخروج من المستشفى
بعد حوالي أسبوع ،
وأرسلت مريضين إلى المنزل في دار رعاية المسنين ،
وذهب أحدهما إلى دار لرعاية
المسنين وسيكون في  الحجر الصحي الإلزامي لمدة 14 يومًا
هناك
وهو لا أعرف ما إذا كان سيعيش بعد
الحجر الصحي ، كان المريض الآخر الذي
خرجت منه في المسكن يبلغ من العمر 41
عامًا وكانت خائفة من الموت بمفردها
والمريضان الآخران اللذين كنت
متزوجين.  زوجان
في الثمانينيات من العمر وقد قبلت
الزوجة في اليوم السابق لي قبل أن أدخل زوجها
إلى المستشفى
وكانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يتم فيها
فصلهما منذ 62 عامًا
، وتمكنا من وضعهما في
غرفة معًا
أم لا.  يمكن أن يكونوا معًا وهو
ما تعرفه بشكل نموذجي  لي أن هؤلاء المرضى الذين يعانون من
الطمع معزولون في
المستشفى وهم وحدهم ليس لديهم
زوار وهم
خائفون وأنا آسف
لأنك تعلم أن احتمال عودة زوجين
في الثمانينيات من العمر إلى المنزل
بعد
قبولهم منخفض لأن الفرص لدى
الناجين ليست جيدة
وزوجة مرضها
ومرضت وتوفيت في المستشفى وكان على
زوجها أن يشاهدها وهي
تموت ولذا كان عليه أن يرى ذلك الخوف وهذا
الحزن أم
وثاني.  لا أعتقد أنه
لا يمكنني وصف
ما نشعر به بالنسبة لنا بصفتنا مقدّمي الرعاية
لضرورة رؤية هذا النوع من المعاناة
من المرضى وأنت
تعلم أنني كنت
في يوم من الأيام في المستشفى ، هذا
كل زملائي.  نشعر بهذا
في
كل مستشفى في
مينيسوتا وأعتقد أنه من الصعب حقًا
فهم
هذا الوزن يا إلهي دكتور جي نحن
آسفون جدًا ومن الواضح أننا جميعًا يمكننا أن نرى
كيف تتسبب في خسائر
لك وأعتقد أنه الشعور بذلك
الناس يموتون
وحدهم  مفجع وأعلم أنه
عندما تتحدث إلى
الأشخاص القادمين وتسألهم من أين
حصلوا عليه
أو كيف حصلوا عليه أو إذا كانوا يعرفون كيف
حصلوا عليه ، ما
الذي يخبرونك به أنك تعرف مركز مقاطعة هينيبين الطبي
حيث أعمل  نحن موجودون في
وسط مدينة مينيابوليس
، ولذا فنحن مستشفى بشبكة
أمان تخدم هذا العدد المذهل والمتنوع حقًا من
المرضى ، لكن
الكثير من المرضى من
المجتمعات المهمشة والأشخاص الذين
لديهم موارد أقل
وإمكانية وصول أقل ، وبالتالي فإن هؤلاء ليسوا كذلك  المرضى
الذين يتم تغطيتهم لأنهم
يذهبون إلى الحانات والمطاعم والحفلات
التي تعرفها ، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين
يحاولون البقاء بأمان ولكنهم
يتعرضون للخطر لأنهم
يتفاعلون مع شخص لديه رغبة في
ذلك وهكذا
نرى الكثير من العمال الأساسيين
الذين لا يستطيعون البقاء في المنزل
أم أننا نرى الكثير من العائلات التي
تعاني من انعدام الأمن السكني لذا ليس لديهم منازل للذهاب إليها ونرى مرضى دار رعاية المسنين الموجودين
بالفعل  آدي معاناة
لأنهم غير مسموح لهم باستقبال زوار وقد
تم عزلهم منذ
أشهر ولكنهم يتعرضون بطريقة ما ،
فنحن نرى عمال رعاية صحية
تعلمون أننا نعتني بالزملاء الذين
نراهم في القاعات كل  اليوم والأشخاص الذين
نعمل معهم ،
يتعين علينا الآن رعاية
المرضى ونرى عائلات بأكملها لا تستطيع
العزلة عن
بعضها البعض تمرض ، لقد اعتنيت
بامرأة
تعرفها بعد أكثر من شهر  في icu
كانت تتعافى
من coven وهذا يجب أن يكون فوزًا
ولكننا كنا نحاول الاتصال بأسرتها
كل يوم لإعطائهم
تحديثًا ولم نتمكن من الحصول على
أي شخص ثم اكتشفنا ذات يوم
أن السبب هو أن زوجها
ماتت من coven وتوفيت ابنتها
أثناء وجودها في المستشفى ،
فكيف تخبر شخصًا
ما كيف تخبر شخصًا ما أن
عائلته قد ماتت